hey welcome everybody there has been
some amazing and huge news going on
right now uh between Damian Lillard
going to the Bucks uh we have drew
holiday going to the Blazers DeAndre
Aiden going to the Blazers but all this
means is that the walks are committing
us and all this means is that we are
going to talk about our contenders and
so for me this year this summer has been
huge and we want to start with number
seven so my seven list is this number
seven we're going with the Phoenix Suns
they've gotten rid of DeAndre Aiden
bolstered their bench they have nurkic
who's a big name in that trade uh they
got a lot of good pieces to come off the
bench but to me when you have a
championship Contender team there can't
be more than one or two what-ifs right
so for me the big what if is what what
are they going to do for interior
defense right I know that they could
score the ball I know that they have
three All-Stars and Bradley Beal Kevin
Durant and Devin Booker but what are
they going to do how is that bench going
to mold and how are they going to be
good defensively
I still think the Suns have some moves
to make
um I think they're gonna need some
obviously Rim protection I think they're
going to need to bring in one or two
more vets uh to really kind of just
solidify that bench
and for me my biggest what if is when
you have guys who've averaged easy 30
points a game how do you get them to
play a point guard position who's going
to be the one to take the back seat I
think
um you know for me it's going to be
Bradley Beal
um everyone knows this is uh Devin
Booker's team but KD is KD he's going to
do his thing and now Bradley Bill's got
to turn into more uh than a to a point
guard
um and so right now Mets fan Abby uh
this sounds better with nerkitch and
Grace and Allen I think
uh I think it's a catch-22 I think you
have two really good role players
um I think you're getting uh good
veterans to me but defensively are they
going to help you uh nerkitch is the
power comes a rebounding
um being there down on a post and I
always think if Denver is number one who
do you have to guard jokic right he's
obviously you need some bodies and right
now I think nurkic's is the only real
body uh so that's why I think the suns
are gonna make
um
to make another move to bolster that big
man to bolster their big men uh and you
know what Aiden is always a loss but I
also think you're not going to get the
best version of Aiden on he's not going
to have the opportunity to to make
mistakes he's still young I think the
Portland Trailblazers got a really great
deal in getting him with Simons
um and Scoot I think that was amazing
for Portland but we're not here for
teams that aren't trying to win we're
here for teams that are trying to win
chips uh and I know hey you're gonna say
sons are crazy but what if you know
uh number six Miami I think you know
Miami lost a couple pieces but I do
think with Drew holiday out there that
would be a huge what if that's my only
what if with Miami uh we've seen what
they're gonna do uh with
the team that they have you know Jimmy's
absolutely dangerous in the playoffs uh
bam at a bio is a fierce
um but again what are they going to do
with Tyler hero are they going to
continue to try to move him
um so hey the the the Miami Heat I'm at
number six
uh number five I have the Warriors it's
hard to put a healthy Warriors team not
entitled contention when you have that
big three with Steve Kerr
um I'm curious how they do with Chris
Paul uh where they position him I'm
curious what their bench is going to
look like
um to me it's hard to not have the
Warriors in your top five every single
year if those guys stay healthy
um the West is going to be a monster
um you know Sacramento is going to be
better I think Dallas is going to be
good obviously the Suns Lakers Clippers
um but yeah to me the Warriors are are
always going to be up there uh number
four is the Celtics and I think the
Celtics are going to be a ridiculous
team the only reason they're not two or
three is because of porzingis's Health I
think porzingis can really help them
with his length his floor spacing uh but
losing Marcus Smart is going to be huge
I watched that Holy conference series I
feel like Marcus Smart was doing a lot
of really great things for them so who's
going to be that next guy to step up
um
you know and somebody said James 6 said
how did Dame slip away from the Miami
Heat uh the Portland Trailblazers need
to do what's best for them uh you have a
great young talent and Scoot uh so you
want to put young guys next to them so
that they can grow kind of like what
Cleveland has done what OKC is doing
um what Orlando and and Utah are trying
to do is really just young guys and grow
them
um you know I think the Warriors Miss
CP3 I think they're gonna have creepy
three coming off the bench it's a true
point guard I think last year
um Jordan Poole was
an amazing basketball player but I just
don't think that he was really running
that second unit so now you can uh put
the second unit
um with a bunch of Shooters and Chris
Paul's gonna run it and control the pace
of the game you know and he's a Hall of
Famer he's an All-Star uh
uh let's go to number three
and that's the Bucks
so to me uh the Bucks have won the best
starting lineups in the league
um I think somebody just wrote it down
so it'll be Dame Pat connington Uh you
have Chris Middleton Giannis and and
Brooke Lopez
um and to me I think I'm you know yeah
Bobby Portis coming off the bench with
six players aren't going to win you a
championship so but obviously they could
be two
um
I think this one-two punch of Damon
Giannis is going to be absolutely
disgustingly amazing to watch uh yeah I
just think when it comes to creating
opportunities for our teammates imagine
that you know that one four screen and
roll with with
um Dame and and Giannis how do you
switch right whoever's guarding Dane
can't guardianes and whoever's
guardianus for the most part can't
guardame so uh this has been pretty
amazing
um number two I have the Lakers I think
the Lakers uh you know I really feel
like they're really focused in this year
this is less about LeBron and more about
A.D more about their bolstering their
bench
um I thought Austin Reeves had a great
summer this summer
um
you know for me I think you really look
at like where A.D is in his career
um I think he's going to have a
resurgent year
um and I could have switched three and
two with the Bucks and the Lakers but I
just went with the team with a bench
um you know the Bucks have a new coach
um for me the Lakers have had that coach
for a year
um and then obviously number one and
then we'll get to is Denver I just think
jokes is unguardable uh yeah like what
are you gonna do that team's been
together for so long I know they lost
Bruce Brown uh but there's so many
people that are going to step up for
this team
um you're looking at their maturity
you're looking at Mike Malone has been
one of the uh more consistent coaches in
the league
um you know for me it's just I really do
have a lot of faith in the nuggets are
going to continue to get better
um so some of the questions they had is
like how hard will it be getting out of
the East for the Celtics I think it's up
to health right I think um I was there
game seven uh I really felt the energy
in that Arena I felt the energy from
that team and the minute that Jason
Tatum twists his ankle uh uh was crazy
so
um I do think they're going to be
amazing and how they're gonna uh deal
with not having Marcus Brogden going to
be uh is Brockton going to be healthy
how is Chris S porzingis going to fit in
that system
um is going to be pretty interesting to
watch throughout the year uh Knicks fan
four what are the Knicks land in the
Eastern Conference
you've been a Knicks are a tough team to
kind of figure out I know they're
they're not going to beat themselves I
think they're always an opportunistic
team
um I think honestly
you know the Knicks are one of those
teams where if you mess around they're
going to take advantage of that I think
they're really I'm excited for them
um I love what they've done really just
getting New York Knicks style players
um everyone's talking about it in the
media about in the next few years which
next Superstar is going to go there so
obviously it's not going to be honest or
Dame so we'll see what's uh what's gonna
happen next
and then Sam Smith 8 says uh who what's
your Finals Prediction uh for me man
Finals Prediction is
probably gonna be
boy
I'm I'm gonna have to say Denver in the
Bucks uh I just as physical as the Bucks
are as tall and as good as they are
defensively
um to me again it's like what is their
bench like what is seven eight nine
gonna do for them I think the Bucks have
usually been a very deep team
um Bobby Portis has come in
um obviously since he's been there and
done great
um and giannis's health I know last year
uh I think he hurt his back and so just
their health is is the biggest thing and
so somebody said uh where the Sacramento
Kings gonna be
you know that's an interesting team uh
they are young what are expectations
going to be like this year after making
the playoffs for the first time in
almost 25 years uh I think again there's
teams that are Championship contenders
then you have your opportunistic teams
like if somebody gets hurt and then you
have teams that are just trying to
develop
um and make and make the playoffs and
make some noise so at Knicks are those
teams that are opportunistic
um along with teams like the Hawks
um you know so in the Knicks I think
those teams are opportunistic and if
they um
do well during the season they really
can uh Make some noise in the playoffs
um I think for me looking at some of
these teams
Drew holiday wherever he goes whether
that is the heat uh you know I had
mentioned the Lakers but I don't think
they can make any moves till December
um maybe the Celtics that would be crazy
to me I think he'd fit in well there
um you know I think Drew holiday for
what he is where he is with Portland
Portland is not looking for a superstar
they're looking for
um easy uh easy going players who are
just going to come in and develop with
their young Talent
um I think for me
um getting some some young players that
can fit along with ayton Simon's uh
you know and and school is going to be
huge also getting some picks so a team
like OKC which has all those things can
really make some noise I think him and
um Shea gilders will be nasty too so uh
it is uh pretty awesome
um I think to go back to some of these
other teams
you know the talk about the warriors uh
is one of those like that team to me
is kind of interesting right you're now
at the point where what does that window
look I think um
I think Steph is Steph right Steph is
one of the best players ever played
basketball Clay is one of my favorite
players to watch uh just resigned
Draymond
um how are they gonna revamp that team
um you know how are they going to really
bolster that bench and score uh off the
you know get scoring off that bench are
they going to play as fast as they used
to and at the end of the day this is now
a big man's league right you know
Giannis is obviously
um one of the better big men in the
league top three yokits dominated last
year the Lakers with A.D and Braun got
bigger most of these teams got bigger
and taller you look at the Celtics they
got taller than bigger
um you know to I I really am interested
to watch The Warriors and see if their
style of play that small ball can still
be effective against teams like Denver
where they have such a dominant big
uh
some of these other questions
um
should the Bucks have hired Monty or doc
or Nick nurse
you know I think at the end of the day
we looked at what Jana said in the media
it was like Hey you know I need to
um
you know I need to be on a team uh with
a lot of with the chance to have a
championship and I think the Milwaukee
Milwaukee Bucks doubled down on that I
think they said what do you need we'll
go get that
um that one-two punch of Lillard and
Giannis I think
if healthy when healthy is the best one
to punch you know uh I just think they
cover all all parts I think their
leadership is one thing that is also
going to be crazy
um I've also played underneath uh Adrian
Griffin and I think he's a a solid solid
coach solid human
um gonna be able to talk to these guys
and challenge them
um
I think when you look at the Bucks they
just need to inject uh some new energy
some new uh new voice a new fight uh you
know and I am CR I think the east
is going to be a monster but I think
there's two or three teams obviously the
ones on here that have really set
themselves apart
um I think they have a chance to to win
and I I kind of agree with that uh I
think so somebody said Alex Bray said
how much did they move up this trade uh
the Bucks and where were they before
this
dang the Bucks are always good man the
Bucks always had a chance uh to me
they're always
top three in the East top four
um
you know I it's all a lot of times with
these older teams
um you just worry about their health
right Giannis goes down he plays in the
first three games but they still lose uh
teams can get hot like the Miami Heat
right they're um
you know really uh opportunistic teams
that are waiting to to rely on those
things to win series or series
um but the Bucks may have been on this
list without Damian Lillard I might say
five but now they go three but they you
know they really should be two
um
you know and again it's it's are the
Bucks done are they going to get more
veterans to come uh it's a long season
to come and play eight seven eight nine
ten those players I think those are
things uh that really I know they have
Jay Crowder so I know that they're gonna
have uh some good veterans to help them
win games
um during the year and so I know I know
a lot of people are like oh Lakers
number two but you know anytime A.D
plays he's one of the top three to five
best players in the NBA so I at the
beginning of the year we always have to
start over and say if this team hasn't
is healthy what are they going to do
we've always said do they have extra
Playmakers do they have a bench do they
have a length right do they have uh guys
coming off the bench that understand
their roles and I think they do so I
know Lakers Bucks are 2-3 but you know
for the purpose of argument's sake we
could put the books that too
um
you know some Chris bucket says what
about the Clippers
I
at a certain point you gotta
you gotta I mean the Clippers would be
seven maybe I love Paul George and Kawhi
I just haven't seen them get over uh
uh you know I just haven't seen him get
over the hump right it's like every
single year it's like one guy goes down
then the next guy goes down so that type
of crazy
um inconsistency in health makes me put
them lower but if they get healthy and
it works out they can be very dangerous
um
let me see so then Frankie Ty or Frankie
t76 it says um Drew just said he'd be a
buck for life did they do him dirty or
is that just part of the game ah
I think they just I think it's part of
the game right I think it is part of the
game and at the end of the day you make
a decision is it drew holiday or do you
right I think you look at that
relationship Drew holiday is one of my
favorite players he's one of everyone's
favorite players
um
to not only uh to watch but like as
respect but you look at an opportunity
to have Damian Lillard with that
relationship with
um Giannis you got to take that chance
right especially for a guy like Guyana
it's a generational Talent
um I just think you have to take those
chances this you can't think three four
years down the line you got to think now
right
um this league there's so much parity
and when you have a guy like Giannis or
yokich or embiid
um some of those guys you're just like
we have to go for it now
um
90 says what do you talks this upcoming
season
so I I really like the Hawks I think the
I think watching them last year
their system is more based for them to
move around uh it's not your turn my
tujante and Trey
um I think watching them in Sim league
and what they were trying to implement I
think that's really going to help them
uh to be more uh I would say energetic
on offense
um and defensively they're going to have
each other's back so I'm interested to
watch them I think they're going to be
opportunistic I think they have talent I
just a team that was 500 last year it's
hard for me to say oh now you're
contenders right uh I want to see what
happens the first 30 games
um and little cap three says wait we're
the Sixers I can't put the Sixers up
there and it's just the truth when your
main guy if you have you know your main
star you have embiid is creating all
this Ruckus before
uh the season you can't go into the
season thinking you're a contender when
you don't even you your main guy ain't
even going to training camp or media day
uh that's a huge what if that's the
biggest what if I think in a league
right now was Damian Lillard now what is
it it's it's James Harden so regardless
of what happens with that what do you
get back
another thing I'm hearing on Twitter is
Sixers are going to be aggressive in
trying to get Drew holiday back now
true holiday goes to the Sixers now we
got to put them up there
I you know I might put the Sixers
shoot
they might be you know we might have to
have a bunch of sevens or sixes heat
Suns and 76ers uh
will be probably in my realm
um
you know and a lot of people are kind of
saying the sun's at seven is bold but
again when you say
I'm not saying they're not talented what
I'm saying is who is going to play what
position and how is that going to work
you have a first year new head coach you
have Katie's first year you have Bradley
Bill's first year nerk's first year how
is that gonna you know get in there how
is that gonna meld in gel and then you
have a whole new bench that's a lot of
whole new
um so I think that they're gonna they're
fair share of games but for me to just
say at the beginning of the year all
these guys are two three four we're
looking at like favorites to win a
championship
I can't say that right now do they have
the talent to do it absolutely but when
you need people to do something new that
they've never been asked to do in their
career that's why I have them seven not
because of the talent or I don't think
they can do it uh I just think that's
when you look at like the what if at the
beginning of the year
um
I think some of the other things that
we're looking at for the heat if we
really want to talk about them it's just
again these are teams that aren't going
to beat themselves right uh
I do think they're gonna miss you know
Max truce I think they're going to miss
a lot of their scoring and what do they
do with Tyler hero right dude a guy is
uh uh you know in trade rumors all
summer
um you know gotta feel a certain way how
does he come back to Camp what do they
get for him
um
you know that's got to be weird uh what
is their bench look like
um what does you know they they had a
deep bench they had a bunch of guys like
that uh so I'll be interested to see
what they do but I don't want to count
the heat out they did go to the NBA
finals uh so for me they I'm putting
them there based on not only the players
but based on uh their upper management
of getting players to play outside of
who they are
um
somebody said we're the Rockets uh
bottom all right I just don't think you
can I think they're the smallest team in
the league
um we have to look at some of the better
teams in NBA they are the biggest teams
in the NBA
um you look at what's dominating the
league right now and that's the length
um but I think the Rockets are still
going to make moves I think they have
talent I think he makes a great coach
um
but that's a lot that's a lot to come
about that's a lot of you gotta you're
not even worried about winning yet
you're worrying about changing a culture
um
you know I I yeah so that's what I had
about the Rockets
um
yeah and I know so people who have the
Celtics at two my question is do you
just not pay attention to Marcus Smart
and what he's done and what does that
role look like and do you expect those
guys coming off the bench to just take
that right you sent Margaret smart to
Memphis Marcus as far as defensive
player of the year
um
yeah I just think that's a big gap for
them especially last year they they the
year they went to the NBA finals uh they
were one of the better defensive teams
in the League last year they won the
better offensive teams in the league
um and their defense kind of slipped
here and there and then all of a sudden
you move off of Marcus Smart who really
helped them uh times keeping the ball
above the free-throw line
um and then you add porzingis and you
know I know we had a amazing year last
year with Washington
um but where is he health-wise I know he
didn't play for a lot via this year he
hurt his ankle and so what does that
wear and tear look like is he going to
play the five
um think about that matchup between
Giannis and you know Giannis and
kristaps right who guards who what does
that do
um and then just who's stepping up for
them off the bench is it brogdan what's
his health like so it's just there's
always questions but all these teams all
seven teams that I've mentioned uh have
a chance they all have a really good
chance of winning this
um
and and a lot of people are saying Derek
white and I believe you
right but I want to see that right I
want to see I don't know I've seen it in
sections but I don't know if I've seen
it for a full 82 games plus playoffs
right I think Derek white is great
um jumping into that role and being that
spark not only starting but coming off
the bench I thought he played great
um in the Eastern Conference Finals who
really gave them a chance
um
somebody asked uh about Memphis
um you know I'm it has nothing to do
with Memphis as a team I think they're
one of the most exciting teams I think
they made a great with Marcus Smart
um my only question is like maturity and
and like when they win a couple games
are they going to win three in a row are
they going to try to win 13 in a row or
23 in a row
um that is my thing and then the huge
I've said this since day one uh
uh Jaron Jackson Jr if he's healthy
they're going to be fine I think he
defensively obviously defensive play of
the year uh he has been just amazing for
that team
um eating up a lot of holes
um and if he could stay healthy I think
this team is obviously going to be uh
one of the better teams in the west
um somebody said DoodleBob or Giannis
and Dame the best duo
excuse me in the league
I mean yeah I mean you kind of got to
say yeah
um you would man health-wise they're
both generally extremely healthy
um
I would say
leader leadership
um defensively uh day or not Dame but
Giannis is
um one of the best if not the best well
the better defensive players in the
league
um you look at how they run a system
they're unselfish
um I'm pretty excited to watch that
matchup uh I think that was something
that the Bucks were missing with
somebody that can literally just go get
a bucket
um and allow Giannis to play two or
three different positions
um but also space the floor
uh but yeah you know guys I I appreciate
you guys uh being here and listening and
uh talking with me you know people say
the Warriors got worse but every time we
say that then they end up doing
something crazy
um and makes for it uh but yeah you know
I'm excited to watch this season I still
think there are some big moves uh to be
made you know it's Drew holiday uh James
Harden and
all types of other things but thank you
guys and uh stay tuned